g'day my name's Lindsay and I'm here
with Lesley for toy and we're Leslie's a
producer on the Assassin's Creed unity
how long roughly did the development
take on a Assassin's Creed unity so so
far it's been about four years the
courts Ephrem Brotherhood actually was
given a mandate to create you know the
next gen of Assassin's Creed
so they started back around 2010 well
that's such a long time so has it been
hard is it is it hard to work on such a
long project and not had a like an
audience's perspective or opinion on it
like to finally release it now what's it
been like well I can't speak for the
core team I myself have only been on it
for a year and a half but for sure you
know when you've been working on
something for a really long time you you
sort of develop a bit of myopia so it's
really fantastic to come to III and get
the kind of feedback that we get in and
it really helps a lot wow that's really
cool something that's I would love to
know is that what's what's the
progression like from the last
Assassin's Creed so with Pirates and the
Black Flag what's how is the new
Assassins Creed any different so the new
Assassin's Creed is built exclusively
for next gen so we're coming on on Xbox
one Playstation 4 and PC and that gave
us the opportunity to really start from
scratch and kind of go back to you know
what is a next-gen Assassin's Creed so
you know we kind of looked at the three
game pillars navigation stealth and
combat and we've made all those things a
lot more deeper and giving players a lot
more choices we've also revamped
everything for online so now you can
play with more friends yeah and it's on
the seamless open world of Paris you
know you can play single-player co-op
side missions you can go seamlessly from
interiors to exterior is underground so
it's really like this great big open
world of Paris during the French
Revolution
something I really loved was coming out
when he sort of comes around a corner
and there's just a giant crowd of people
and one of the developers is talking
about how it's something like 2,000
2,000 characters can be on a screen at
any time that's incredible can you tell
us any more improvements in that sort of
sense technology wise yeah so I mean we
really really wanted to fill the city
and make it a living and breathing world
so the crowds are systemic you know
during the French Revolution there were
all these rival factions so that's
actually gonna happen while you're there
so you're gonna be walking through the
city of Paris and you know these people
are gonna be fighting these factions
will be fighting in the background you
can choose to intercept and join and if
you want or you can kind of you know I
want to stay safe I'm just gonna like
sneak around these guys and not get
involved
yeah that's similar to my game style I
like to hide and and take them out
systematically one by one but um oh well
that's really cool I'm super pumped to
play that game and I'm looking forward
to it it's nice to meet you great it's
really great to meet you too
congratulations thank you very much